okay we we've got what potentially is
pretty major news that is broken in the
last 24 hours
related to a bunch of different issues
and I want to start with sort of this
set up which is that under most
presidencies the statements of European
sex workers escorts as they're sometimes
known they don't really become relevant
in our understanding of how the
president came to power in the United
States it's sort of irrelevant this is a
different sort of administration and the
New York Times is reporting it's not
Infowars it's not whoever it's the New
York Times that a Belarusian escort
who's connected to this Russian Oleg a
oligarch Oleg Deripaska has 16 hours of
audio recordings which she says prove
that Russia meddled in American
elections and you might remember Oleg
Deripaska he's the Russian billionaire
that's connected to Vladimir Putin who
also did business with the indicted
Trump campaign Chairman Paul Manafort
this is an escort named Anastasia
vashu kovitch and prepare yourselves for
the same people on the Left who claim to
defend women and argue that everyone
should be treated decently regardless of
their occupation be prepared for that
element of the left who is also part of
the Russia denier crowd to smear this
woman because of her position as an
escort which they've already started to
do anastasia bouche of a shukhevich is
currently in prison in thailand and
she's saying that she will turn over 16
hours of recordings to the United States
if the u.s. grants her political asylum
how insane is this she's currently
facing charges in Thailand for allegedly
working there without a visa in a sex
training seminar and the frequency with
which porn stars escorts and prostitutes
are coming up in relation to the Trump
administration is truly stunning and I
actually don't think we have to make any
evaluations of her credibility on the
basis of her job either the recordings
exist or they don't either the
recordings point to Russian meddling in
Trump's election or they don't and you
might say well David is there any reason
to think that this random
skort who's currently being detained in
Thailand might even possibly have these
recordings or is this sort of appearing
out of thin air well last night or the
night before there was a 25-minute video
investigation that was posted by a
Russian opposition figure named Alexei
Navalny
which contains many videos and pictures
taken by this woman so at minimum we can
say she has provided videos and
recordings previously the ones that have
already been released our videos where
she says Deripaska would meet with Paul
Manafort Manafort would give Deripaska
information on the Trump campaign and
then would get paid for that and the
presumption of course is that Deripaska
would then go and directly briefed
Vladimir Putin about what was going on
she says she was modeling when she was
sent to a yacht owned by Russian
oligarch Deripaska that the recordings
contain admissions related to
russian-american relations and
interference and she claims that some of
these recordings contains specific
discussions about the 2016 American
election the most important line from
the New York Times report could be that
some of the recordings she claims to
have involve conversations with three
people who spoke what to her was fluent
American English that she believed to be
American if the tapes exist and they are
what she claims they are
I wonder who those three Americans might
be I don't know but I would be very
interested to know and I hope that the
tapes if they exist have been copied and
that some kind of failsafe is in place
in case harm comes to her because that's
what I'd be worried about right now and
there's no greater evidence than tapes
it seems I mean you think about what
brought down the Nixon administration
yeah it was the tapes what nearly
brought down the Trump campaign the
access hollywood tapes that's accepted
this could be big and I like that we
even still use the word tapes like at
this point they're probably not even
really tapes but it has this sort of or
around the use of the word tapes now
alternatively we can refrain its fake
news nothing to see here
my concern is if it's true that Trump is
compromised by Russia it might not be
safest form is V shukhevich to go to the
American State Department for asylum
right she might actually be better off
going to the Netherlands or Germany or
somewhere else because we don't know
depending on who's in charge of granting
her asylum in the United States and
depending on which if any of the
allegations about the current
administration are true I don't know
that the people making the decision
about her Asylum would be inclined to
say yes specifically because they might
not want these tapes to be released
there is no doubt in my mind that if she
truly has 16 hours of tapes as she
describes she is certainly not safe in a
Thai prison and hopefully this is going
to be hopefully we have news about a
change to where she is sooner than later
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show is
on twitter at david pakman show we'll
take a break in just a major breaking
news day today today's program is
brought to you in part by Blink Asst so
you read books I read books and if
you're at all like me you probably don't
have time in your schedule to read all
the books that you want to read there is
an entire world of nonfiction books out
there that could really feed your
knowledge and infla intellect but the
sad truth is that you're only able to
read or tiny fraction of those books but
what you could still do is absorb the
most essential knowledge from the books
that you don't have time to read and
that's exactly where blinka comes in
it's an app that takes nonfiction books
pulls out the most important points and
insights from the books and it puts them
in a condensed sort of packaged form
which you can either read or listen to
in about 15 minutes on your mobile
device or tablet and over four million
people are already using Blinky's it
made the iTunes best apps of 2017 list
and you can choose from a selection that
is huge thousands of books all of which
you'll have access to as the
blinka subscriber and you can switch
between text and audio both online and
offline get personalized recommendations
based on the books you've already chosen
blink astiz free to try and membership
after that is only a few bucks a month
but you can get a 20% discount if you go
to blink is comm slash Pakman and if
you're watching on youtube we are
linking a tube Linkous and our link in
the video description one more time that
is blink is comm /p a que ma n